before the uprising in 2011 syria was
able to feed itself
but years of war and now a severe
drought has made this nation a net
importer of wheat
over the past two to three years uh the
whole country has been hit by a
crippling drought
that its impacts are felt mostly in the
northeast which is traditionally the
bread basket of the country
let alone areas that are in the
northwest of the country or regime held
areas
the rise in global prices sparked by
russia's invasion of ukraine is
threatening food supplies to many people
in syria the country is among the 10
most food insecure nations in the world
12 million people struggle to get enough
food many of them live in the opposition
controlled north
we have limited incomes and yet we have
to rely on expensive imported wheat
because much of the land in this region
is mountainous we can't grow much wheat
and lands where wheat can be grown are
not accessible vast areas were set on
fire by government forces during the
conflict and irrigation channels were
destroyed and even though there is now
less violence front lines still exist
we are close to the regime positions
many people can't reach their land
because it is dangerous
humanitarian organizations as well as
the local authorities are helping
farmers to produce more food but it's
costly to plant crops so is transporting
the harvest due to high fuel prices
fuel is also needed to pump groundwater
to make up for what is being described
as syria's worst drought in 70 years
in the opposition held area in the north
production won't be enough
this year 30 000 hectares were
cultivated but the low rainfall and high
production costs hurt farmers a ton of
wheat costs 450
we will have to import more than 30 000
tons this year the average annual amount
of wheat production before the war was
3.7 million tons this declined to 1.8
million tons between 2015 and 2019.
harvests are shrinking
and farmers are fighting to survive and
with more than half of syria's people
already hungry the agricultural crisis
couldn't come at a worse time zen
al jazeera
all right well for more on this let's
speak to marco sanchez the deputy
director of the agri-food economics
division at food and agricultural
organization he's joining us live from
skype via brussels thanks for your time
sir as we heard there this seems like a
perfect storm of problems you've got the
war in ukraine affecting supply chains
you've got drought in certain parts of
the world how is the agricultural sector
surviving through this
um thank you very much my pleasure to be
here well you know
the way i call this is just the tip of
the iceberg what is happening today in
agri-food systems uh
is very worrisome
uh but basically is the confirmation of
something that the food and culture
organization of the united nations have
been observing for many many years
uh back in 2017 when we launched the
same report that we are launching today
but back then we had identified conflict
as a very key driver of foreign security
and managed issue in the world we will
observe the hangar was declining for a
decade and then all of a sudden it
started to increase again and we're
wondering what is going on so we we
started identifying these key drivers
and conflict turned out to be one of
them today we have a conflict but to us
it is not new it's just a conflict that
engages two big players in many respects
for like the good systems but it's a
conflict that we knew already conflicts
all over the world were affecting the
numbers but also the other key drivers
are
climate climate adversities climate
adversity that we can no longer predict
uncertainty that's another of the key
drivers of food in security and
malnutrition and then you add to that
economic downturns that we're observing
even before the covet 19 pandemic there
were crisis economic crisis all over the
world that were increasing the problems
now the covenanting pandemic comes just
to add with all its strength
more economic slowed down due to the
measures to contain it
and these key drivers climate conflict
and economic slowdowns are creating more
problems because not only are they
intensifying themselves but also they
are having combined effects
and on top of that they create a lot of
problems for the more vulnerable because
of the existing inequalities the word
comes and makes things worse as you say
but it's just the tip of the eyebrow you
know
as you mentioned there of course how do
you even measure hunger it obviously
means different things to different
people in the same way that poverty
means different things to different
people around the world how would you
define hunger
sure we have uh the the the let's say
the traditional indicator that we use
which is one of the official united
nations indicators to trace uh
the evolution or the progress of the
world toward the zero hunger goal which
is a sustainable development goal is
called the prevalence of the nourishment
and basically what this number tries to
do is through official data that feo
receives from countries i understand if
people are at least you know meeting the
minimum energy requirements to live a
healthy life
now hunger is chronic and that's why we
measure it to the prevalence of the
nourishment but
the food and security problem is bigger
than hunger
and what we have been doing also is
creating
a
new indicators precisely because of what
you said
the people may have different ways of
both defining hunger but also
experiencing hunger so fao in this
report in 19 and 2019
released a new indicator that we call
the moderate or severe food insecurity
and this indicator is differently
constructed because it is based on
surveys that we ask to households to
peoples to children to women to the the
head of the household to understand what
is the perception what is their
experience in terms of the hunger and it
turns out that the severe foreign
security by that indicator is very
consistent with the traditional
prevalence of the knowledge indicator
even though they come from very
different methodologies so in that
regard the the bad news is that both
indicators are telling us that in all
regions of the world the problem of food
insecurity is increasing and severe food
insecurity and the privilege of
undernourishment which are two measures
of chronic anger are telling us that we
are going in the wrong direction
marco sanchez from the food and
agriculture organization thank you
my pleasure